hi there we are here at the nerves 2019
poster session one of the poster
sessions specifically there are two
poster sessions a day three days so this
is day two the first poster session is
technically lunchtime so most people are
out but you can see there's still so
many people are here there are about 250
posters in this room and every poster
has like a ball of people around it and
this isn't even like this is not peak
time yesterday they didn't even let
people into this room feel like that's
the kind of the only reason you come to
the conference to actually talk to the
people doing the work but it's almost
impossible because they're constantly
trying to explain in the present trying
to explain their work to about 20 people
at a time asking any meaningful
meaningful questions in getting into a
conversation is almost impossible and
yeah it's about 10 degrees warmer in
here than outside it is sweaty it smells
it's absolutely beautiful
yeah it's I don't know like there is a
kind of a feeling in the air that this
is a bubble just a sheer amount of
people attending this it's crazy and I
don't know what this looks like in a few
years maybe this is peak or maybe it's
just going to grow and grow and grow
I don't know but yeah so you can see
what it looks like and maybe I've
described well what it feels like to be
here alright so with that I am going to
dive in and my life